[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings at 7 30.
today we're looking at the long-term
effects of covid on some children and
we're doing so as many parents of course
have younger kids consider getting them
vaccinated so far the cdc estimates
about 900 thousand children in the u.s
between the ages of 5 and 11 have
received their first dose and it comes
as we learn a recent uk study found that
covid still affects
one in seven children months after
infection meg oliver now has more on
these long-hauler symptoms
[Applause]
at first glance it's hard to believe
this energetic little four-year-old is
anything other than healthy but it has
taken a year for erin estrada to get
here
this was aaron in november 2020 needing
oxygen to breathe in a hospital bed for
more than a week after contracting covid
his hair started falling out he had
heart problems and he couldn't walk or
stand for a month do you remember
after you got sick
how it made your legs feel
[Music]
aaron developed a severe covet related
life-threatening condition called
multi-system inflammatory syndrome in
children which causes major organs to
become inflamed concepcion ruiz and
federica estrada are aaron's parents
what was going through your mind que
it was very sad emotional
one study of long-covered symptoms in
children suggested that more than half
between 6 and 16 years old who get covet
have at least one symptom that lasts
more than 120 days
are you seeing an increase in the number
of kids with long-haul or symptoms we
are dr catherine klauser and her team at
hackensack meridian health in new jersey
opened one of the first pediatric covid
recovery centers in the state last
spring to help erin and kids like him
what are long-hauler symptoms
in children we tend to see that they
have persistent fatigue some kids are
having persistent headaches and a lot of
kids are having anxiety symptoms that
maybe they didn't have before a recent
study found young people with
pre-existing conditions are 25 times
more likely to get severe covet than
those without but aaron had no known
pre-existing conditions nor did year old
madison four from michigan it feels
like scary like i just can't breathe
madison is a competitive dancer she was
healthy and thriving before she got
covet in january she never used an
inhaler before but 10 months later she
still needs one and gets winded easily
especially while dancing i get really
tired and i need to sit down and
my heart starts pumping really fast and
my lungs it's just like
constant need for air mariah lin-4 is
madison's mom i'm worried that
[Music]
this could have done more damage than
what we even realized
but i'm also worried that she'll also
need the inhaler for the rest of her
life to do things such as take long
walks or bike rides or need it for dance
oh show me your muscles
as for aaron doctors are hopeful that
with time and continued treatment he
will make a full recovery what do you
want to say to your doctors who helped
you learn how to walk again
children are eligible for the pfizer
vaccine once they turn five years old
aaron doesn't turn five until the spring
but his doctors want him to get the
vaccine this month given how severe his
reaction to kovid was his doctor told us
she hopes the vaccine will help decrease
long-haul cases and there is already
some evidence it's reducing long-hauler
symptoms in kids like aaron
aaron's so cute we want him to be okay
gracias one of the most important words
you can say that's right gracias and
thank you and thank you meg oliver thank
you very much